I'm making this video to say hi to my
viewers and listeners in China and also
to wish them happy new year.
I was prompted to do so by Ms Dot
Mangee,
a Chinese students studying in Germany
who has worked diligently to translate
and subtitle a number of my videos.
I've placed links to those in the
description of this video.
Mangy has also organized a number of
people to work on the translations.
They have a group on Weebo,
which I have linked to in the
description.
Thanks mangy.
Much appreciated.
I would also like to announce that my
new book,
12 rules for life will be translated
into Chinese and published by Beijing
cheers books.
I don't know the publication date yet,
but I will let everyone know as soon as
I do.
Links to the publisher are also in the
description.
I am extremely pleased to hear that my
lectures are finding an audience in
China and happy new year to everyone
there.
Bye for now.